well hello there you're watching the
press preview first look at what's on
the front pages
as they arrive in the next half an hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the journalist and author rachel
shabby
and the former conservative party
advisor anita boateng good evening to
you both see you
in a moment but let's take a look at
first of all what's on our front pages
this evening and the observer is
carrying details that it's obtained
about the number of sexual abuse claims
made against officers of the
metropolitan police
the telegraph hears that sas soldiers
are to be tasked with working alongside
mi6
against russian spies scotland on sunday
is reporting that the uk government is
forcing delegates attending the upcoming
cop 26 climate change conference in
glasgow
to book through its official
accommodations provider and therefore
pay nearly 900 pounds a night for hotel
rooms
that would usually cost around 50.
according to the sunday times two
candidates to be the next speaker of the
house of lords are calling for
hereditary peerages to be abolished
because they believe they are outdated
okay well as i say we're joined tonight
by rachel shabby and anita boateng let's
dive straight in shall we with
a story on the front of the observer
anita and this is about
uh the fears that there may be an
extension of covid
travel rules as we see this third wave
sweeping across europe what do you take
of it
well i do think the government has been
very careful not to make too many
commitments
um about what's going to happen with
regard to foreign travel
and i you will remember matt hancock
repeatedly saying we're going to have a
fantastic
british and summer emphasis on the
british
and i think it's absolutely right the
government hasn't promised too much
so it's not going to end up
disappointing people when it comes to
foreign plans and i think you know
the home secretary for instance pretty
patel has also said you know do not book
those flights and i think that message
will continue
particularly as we're on the verge
potentially of a third wave across
europe
i mean it's been a hot topic today
hasn't it rachel we've not been hearing
much from the government on it
preferring instead to focus perhaps
quite rightly
on the vaccination situation but reading
some of the details in this article the
suggestion that there might be a traffic
light system so that travel could
be allowed perhaps to uh some countries
that are green
on the traffic light system yeah
that's right that's one of the things
that's been suggested by
sections of the conservative government
that actually
uh want to what they want international
travel to resume so boris johnson
is under pressure as usual from uh
backbench mps who
basically want him to be opening up more
quickly and particularly on this issue
of foreign travel overseas travel so
that's one of the things they've
suggested but it's interesting to note
that his
that has been his achilles heel
throughout um
the journalists from the inside team who
just published a book about what they
described as the
scandalous political mismanagement of
this government and the pandemic
one of the things that they note in this
book is that
um the reason some of the reasons for
johnson's repeated dithering and
delaying and slow lockdowns
which was one of the greatest mistakes
throughout the last year
was pressure from his backbench mps and
we can see
that it's rising now over the issue of
overseas travel and when to open up but
that does go against
uh the advice of uh johnson's own
scientific advisors on sage who are
saying
you know it's extremely unlikely that we
will be able to
um travel to mainland europe over the
summer that it's just
too much risk too soon anita i can see
you shaking your head whilst rachel was
speaking there i want to give you an
opportunity to come back to those points
i i just think that rachel fundamentally
misunderstands the prime minister she
thinks that's been the issue
i think fundamentally the prime minister
himself is very much you know a
libertarian
in his instincts are not to lock down as
much as possible and i certainly think
that
he's following his own political
instincts in wanting to
ensure that there is reasonable
compliance ensuring that we
follow the science and ensuring that we
learn as we go
and i just think that this
characterization of the entire
pandemic as being one of boris johnson
repeatedly responding to back bench
pressure
is to misunderstand the way his politics
works and i certainly think that if it
were
within his power he would want people to
be traveling across europe but at the
moment there are just too
many vagaries that mean that it's going
to be difficult to make that kind of
commitment right now
and ultimately it depends on what europe
does
um and how it manages to to you know
manage its own
crisis um and so that's not within the
gift of the prime minister
and of course i just forgot i just
wanted to be very clear that i'm i'm
quoting
uh an investigations team that have
written the book
um and that book is based on a year-long
research
in which they spoke to not just
scientific advisors but insiders in
johnson's
own government so that's where that was
coming from okay
well let's turn our attention to the
sunday telegraph they are
running this story about making more
jabs on our own soil
and this is in the face of a growing
crisis over in
mainland europe anita what's your view
on that i mean if that's possible it
seems like a sensible solution
i mean i think that the uk has very much
covered itself in glory both astrazeneca
um and oxford university deserve an
enormous amount of credit
for the logistical undertaking not not
to mention the scientific
know-how that is required to produce
this kind of vaccine
at such huge quantities and i think that
actually the uk
has done a very good job and the
government has done a fantastic job
in creating an environment that makes it
attractive and efficient to manufacture
in the uk
and i also think the eu has not covered
itself in glory
in its handling of the pandemic and its
protectionist interests
and instincts around what happens with
the vaccine when there are supply
complications
which is inevitable when you're
producing something that is
so incredibly complicated i think has
definitely
led the eu to make some really rogue
calls and i think that unpredictability
is what the uk government wants to guard
against i mean ursula vonderline
certainly raised a lot of eyebrows this
week didn't she rachel shabba with
suggestion that they might
uh try and block uh the export of
vaccines to the uk where our
program is is going on great guns
she most certainly did and i i agree
that the the eu has handled the vaccine
issue badly several occasions already
this year
i do think that there's a problem here
which is to do with
actually links to the story about
overseas travel
which is of course that you know until
everyone is vaccinated
none of us is is safe and none of us has
the sort of freedoms that we are
very keen to go back to and i think
there's a wider problem here which is to
do
with why it's so hard
to produce vaccines at speed and
actually that's nothing to do with
political or whatever spats between the
eu or anyone else
it's to do with patents and
you know really if we want the entire
world to be
vaccinated and at the moment there's a
huge discrepancy
between the western world and the rest
of the world
who will who cannot get the same access
to the vaccines what we need to see
is those vaccines to be produced off
patent
so that actually they can be made
everywhere and then we can see
distribution ramp up to the scale
that it needs to be for us all to
receive that jab
going anita you want to dive in at that
point no i i just wanted to say that i
really do commend the government though
for its role in kobach
so that's a process whereby um the the
uk
and other countries in the western world
helped to fund supplies of vaccines to
developing countries and i think that's
going to be
incredibly important moving forward and
you know there may well be some more
difficult con
decisions for the government to make as
this process continues about
given the number of vaccines that the uk
has you know once the adult population
in the uk has been vaccinated
there's then a question about where the
the excess vaccines go
yeah and the issue of excess vaccines
almost seems a distant uh luxury as we
look to april where there seems to be a
shortage anyway in the short term
and that brings us neatly on to the
sunday times that where there's uh
reports of cheats posing as care workers
jumping up the vaccine q which will
you know given that there is a shortage
and a pressure and all of the concerns
surrounding it will it will anger a lot
of people
it will but i i wonder i mean as you
rightly said it it has just been
you know it's partly a response to this
news of this shortage and the
announcement
that there's going to be uh a delay
in terms of reaching the next levels of
ages that can be vaccinated so the under
50s in particular
might have to wait longer than was
originally thought
although let's be clear that's in the
context
of the vaccine rollout accelerating at
speed
with over 50 percent of the population
already vaccinated
but the sunday times is reporting that a
few people are
ticking the box of you know care worker
and therefore
booking appointments at vaccine centers
only to find of course that they're then
turned away because you do actually need
proof
that you are a carer or equivalent to to
be
um entitled to that jab so let's hope
that that
is just a little blip because
overwhelmingly
the story of vaccines and the way
vaccine centers have been running not
just with
amazing nhs staff but also incredible
volunteers
that has been on the whole positive so
far yeah and anita
what a record that's been reached today
with over half of all uk adults now
having had their first dose and
i think it was one percent of the uk
population being vaccinated in one day
which is really quite remarkable
it really is and the other thing that we
really should pay attention to
is the levels of willingness to take up
the vaccine
and i personally was quite concerned
about the initial reports for instance
about bme population
and how willing they were to take the
vaccine and i think what we've seen
which is is as the vaccine roller has
progressed and more people have you know
know friends and family who have taken
the vaccine and it's you know been very
effective and it's been safe
i think that's really helped to make the
british public feel
comfortable going forward for the
vaccine when their time comes
i also do want to say that you know
really
this is a remarkable achievement for our
country and it is
also incredibly remarkable that at the
moment what is
seems to be a very minor slowing down in
what has been a
a significant acceleration in the roller
of the vaccine
you know that that is not bad going
considering that actually a lot of
people are expecting
the vaccine rollout program or if you
were in your 30s or 40s to be getting
the vaccine
optimistically in october november you
know the government really has massively
over delivered
in this regard and that's why we've seen
such tremendous milestones such as
what's happened
today and perhaps made a road for its
own back now having to deliver those
second doses within 12 weeks but huge
amount of pressure and
we'll have more from rachel and anita in
a moment including looking at this paper
do
hereditary peerages still have a place
in modern britain that's on the front of
tomorrow's
sunday times we'll discuss that in a few
moments time
[Music]
i've never been into an institution
that's been willing to just lift up the
lid and say
look we're in a crisis it's been a
living nightmare to work
we've lost people in their 30s in their
40s
i've been in nursing for 20 years this
is like another level
i don't think we'll ever get back to
normal that's now history
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now rachel shabby and
anita boateng
we're taking a look at the sunday papers
for you let's start anita
with the front of the sunday times um
really hard to defend isn't it this when
you see in stark black and white
zero female hereditary peers they don't
even list the number
of black and ethnic minority hereditary
peers because well
i'm assuming that is zero as well but
all this coming up because of the
lord's speaker election coming up
yes and i mean hold the front page there
are no women and no ethnic minorities
that are hereditary peers in the
in the house of lords look i mean this
story isn't surprising
um but i also think that it's
interesting that the
times has given the front page to this
and i think particularly this point
about
by-elections is quite an interesting one
um i don't think it would shock
many people to know that 39 of the peers
are
uh went to eaton or that um you know
there's ever average age of a hereditary
pier was 71.
um but it does highlight the kind of the
wider point which is that
even in a system in the house of lords
which you can definitely call
traditional and historic and there are
some elements of it that are more
challenging than others and i certainly
think this point about
by-election so this process where our
heritage peers vote
for each other to inherit um new seats
when when someone dies
um that can be pretty archaic and so i
think it's interesting that the times
has given a front page to
talking again and reigniting that
conversation around
hereditary peers okay rachel anita calls
it not particularly surprising but
there are arguments in the article
saying that it devalues democracy and
when it's a time of election
good time to talk about it isn't it i
mean i'll say it does
i i mean you might call it traditional
and historic i personally would call it
anachronistic and
outdated and having no place in you know
in
2021 i mean it's quite it's quite
shocking nonetheless whatever we already
know or think we know it is quite
shocking to see those figures in
you know stark front page like that 46
percent of her edu peers went to eaton
the average age of 71. of course no
women because it still
bizarrely uh works on the basis of you
know
predatory succession and then there's a
bit more detail
in the body of this piece about um
you know 50 million claimed in um
expenses since 2001. um
most of them have spoken just 50 times
in the last 50 years
and when they do speak 60 percent of the
time it's about business or personal
matters so you have to wonder
what actually the value to our democracy
is of having this system
persist and whether it does actually
erode our democracy
that it does still carry on okay
speaking about value
i want to quickly go to the scotland on
sunday
we're just talking about the upcoming
cop 26 conference in glasgow
later on this year hotels are being
priced at 12 000 pounds for people
attending anita
look well i think what the government
has said is that people are free to not
book these hotels so it does feel as
though
there's quite an obvious out for people
for whom it would be
a stretch i mean i think cop is going to
be a fantastic event
i think it's really important that there
is adequate you know security and
resources and
actually i hope it will be a really
fantastic thing for the um the glasgow
hotel sector
and more broadly because i mean
ultimately hospitality has had
an incredibly difficult year and there
may be many hotel chains that may not
survive
so you know i i kind of think you can go
somewhere else and you can also
support the glasgow economy what could
be better than that
okay thoughts rachel i mean
it's it it's being the government is
being accused of running a monopoly here
in terms of the accommodation at the
climate summit
and the point is that it would actually
prevent
people from poorer countries delegates
from portugal countries being able to
attend
not to mention that it goes entirely
against the spirit
of of the summit and just to put it into
context the accommodation of these
these events is usually as low as 50
pounds according to this piece
uh whereas in this case it's up to 888
pounds
per night